as the question says you're going to
need a new set of axes for these so go
ahead draw a new one do it beside and
what we're going to do is graph not this
not not f of X we want to graph f of X
minus 2 so think back to your function
notation so this is much earlier in the
year what this means is everywhere you
saw an X please replace it with an X
minus 2 yeah that's what that means okay
so therefore what I've got is we're
gonna do this together right now oh yes
you're sorry what this function notation
means is everywhere you saw an X replace
it with an X minus 2 okay if I've
written say hey what's F of 5 right I'd
say everywhere it's thrown X put a 5 in
right if I'd written you know f of Ceran
I'd say everywhere sorry an X put in a
surrender like I don't know why you do
that but if you wanted to that's what
the notation means can we think
algebraically let's get this um that's
distracting user let's get this f of X
minus 2 into our heads so firstly f of X
it had an x squared at the front yeah
I'm not gonna write x squared for this
guy everywhere I saw an X I'm going to
replace it with an X minus 2 so it'll be
X minus 2 all squared is that Alright
exposed to all squared that's not the
only X that appears in my function I've
got X minus 1 here so I'll replace that
guy with X minus 2 so it becomes X minus
3 minus 1 you care with that but of
course I can tidy that up can I write
let's write this as X minus 2 all
squared what should I write in here X my
straight thank you John okay
X minus 3 all right now I've asked you
to graph this guy okay okay you're using
some extension language a which is great
let's let's think about together how
this graph is related to that graph okay
in the first instance remember how we um
Mac suggested we find some x intercepts
that's where we began and we did it and
that was very helpful we can do exactly
the same thing here but because we've
kind of already looked at a very similar
version this function a lot of the
mental leg work has already been done
so you've already got your set of actors
there I haven't so let me play catch-up
I'm actually gonna grow this way so when
you have a look
I got 0 and 1 as my x-intercepts should
have written that actually x-intercepts
I got them from here and here right
how will look here I'm gonna get
different x-intercepts on time what are
my x-intercepts gonna be this time
that's negative 1 2 & 2 okay now I can
see where you get to from that's where I
got that from from where did your
negative 1 come from times 1 by mega
which part of you looking at oh you mean
if you expanded this out and so what
happened okay now let's take this idea
that max has got here you saw before
that I could expand this out if I wanted
to because we've got sort of more growth
numbers here it'll be a little more
time-consuming but you could still do it
if you wanted
however in this case when you're
searching for these intercepts leaving
it in factorized form is actually going
to be easier for you let me illustrate
when x equals 2 right
what does that part that is uncovered
what is it equal to minus 2 all squared
what's that equal to that's 0 right
because 2 minus 2 0 u square 0 you still
get 0
right so for that reason when x equals 2
I don't care what this thing is because
it's 0 times some stuff still 0 now I'm
going to repeat that process over here
and I can do this because it's
factorized what value of x I want to put
in here x equals 3 right when I do x
equals 3 that's going to become 0 and
then I don't care what this other thing
becomes because it'll be 0 times some
other stuff
it'll still be 0 that's the thing I'm
searching for does that make sense so
the 2 and the 3 rather than 0 and 1
that's where my new tips are can you go
ahead and draw them for me the 0 sorry
the 2 and the 3 so try and pay close
attention 1 2 3
okay so here my crosses right here my
crosses now at this point I asked you
before hey is this enough information to
graph and you said no well we can
actually add another piece of
information here
remember in Part A by finding the
x-intercepts coincidentally we found the
y-intercept do we already know what the
y-intercept is for this guy we haven't
worked out it we just kind of skipped
over that all right
oMG right so how do we find the
y-intercepts in this case strain let X
equal 0 perfect
let's you've already got it ok let's
confirm what strings answer is by making
sure we've got this together here's my
function y equals all that stuff when I
put in x equals 0 when x equals 0 what
I'm getting is y equals 0 take away 2
squared times 0 minus 3 I know you know
what 0 take away 2 is I know you know at
0 take away 3 years but I write the
substitution step number one to show I
know what I'm doing number two so I
didn't screw it up because the more
stuff I keep in my head the more the
easier it is to make am a mistake
because you've overloaded your working
memory so this is what I'm writing down
what is 0 take away 2 it's negative 2
what is 0 take away 3 negative 3
negative 2 all squared 4 and like Sarang
said and he's calculator that's negative
12 okay
so that information y equals negative 12
tells me the y-intercept it's gonna be
way down low here okay so I'm gonna put
that over here near 12 that's 2 and
that's 3 now if you wanted you could go
ahead and you could again plot a point
between 2 & 3 you know how he plotted a
point with 0 and 1 and I'm pretty sure
you got 1/2 and I think it was negative
1/8 wasn't it know your name okay now if
you'd like you could go and take a value
like 2 and 1/2 which is also between 2 &
3 you could pop it into your calculator
and see what happens
I'm just going to put some money down
that you're going to get negative 1 over
8 and I'd love you to go ahead and
verify that on your calculator now how
did I know that how do I work that out
it's not Bishop
because I've got black magic dark sort
of skills it's not because I just sort
of worked it out actually didn't do any
calculation at all you did the
calculation see how we've got these two
features zero and one
do you notice they're related to those
two features over there zero and one
became two and three yes so they sort of
slid over like that this spot over here
which we didn't label because it wasn't
important wasn't intercept or anything
like that there's gonna be some spot
where it's negative twelve right and
that's become this guy so it's slid over
to the left
and in fact everything has moved on to
the right everything has moved over to
the right by how many units are you
gonna guess to right so if I'm looking
at a spot that's exactly two units over
from this guy it should be equal to
whatever you worked out it was before so
I can take that same shape and let's see
how we go Hugh I'm reasonably happy with
that it's the same shape we call this
think back to you seven when you were
learning about geometry this is called a
translation you slid it over same thing
all of this fancy algebra champ obscures
it right when you look at this all you
do is you slide it shift it over you're
good to go horizontal shift okay does
anyone have any questions
at that point trial this year okay so I
can do this in one of two ways number
one I could go the long way so I'm just
searching for my black marker I could go
the long way and I could take this guy
here and I could input two and a half I
could substitute it my calculator would
do all the crunching for me and this is
what you would get okay or alternatively
the fact that I know these two graphs
are not just two random graphs they're
the same graph but their position is
changed and so the fact that you told me
this earlier
that's what I took advantage of okay